Whoopi Goldberg was on The View
and
Wolfie made a claim about
American law and culture and just what
it what it means to be an American and
Whoopi says
Banning books and banning drag queens
that is just downright
un-American I'm not willing to give you
access to my body I'm just not willing
to do that that is none of your business
what goes on in my family is none of
your business like I feel like if you
don't want to see drag shows then don't
take your child to a drag show if you
don't want your child reading certain
books give the library a list of the
books you don't want your kid to to read
stay off my back because my rights are
just as important as yours and when it
comes to what I do with my family and my
body it's none of your business it is up
to you
to know what your kids are reading if
you want to know go to the school if
it's not a book you're interested in
tell the teacher you don't want your kid
reading it but don't get in the way of
my kid being able to read that book that
is not American get off my back that is
not American okay so before we get into
Whoopi's confused philosophy just as an
historical point
Banning books is very American
Banning drag shows is obviously very
American for much of American History
throughout the country including in San
Francisco transvestitism was completely
illegal you would be arrested for public
disturbance if you ever did that
all sorts of weird sexual behaviors were
illegal in the United States until the
Supreme Court invented some right to do
weird sex stuff in the mid-2000s okay so
it is deeply deeply American to
prescribe this sort of weird Behavior
but even Banning books has always for
all of American History has been very
very much a part of of American public
life
obviously going back to the Puritans
they banned all sorts of books in fact
there was one guy who was ex ostracized
from The Colony by Governor Bradford for
writing poems that were a little bit
licentious a little bit lascivious
and they almost executed him for it but
then they just banished him to an island
so he could wait for an English ship to
come by and take him back to Britain
and then obviously up through the
founding era
all sorts of laws against obscenity
in fact these laws against obscenity
were being exercised at the federal
level as recently as 2008
the guy was in prison until 2011 one of
the pornographers that they threw in
jail but furthermore it's not it's not
just the
Christians and the conservatives Banning
books quite the opposite it's the libs
since the middle of the 20th century
it's the libs who say you can't teach
the Bible in schools
you oh no we better not find any
teachers with a Bible in school we're
going to get the ACLU on your back
that's right the American civil
liberties Union we're going to go after
you for having a Bible in schools you
better not recite any prayers in schools
oh no sir Ray
this is America one nation under God
we're not going to let you teach the
Bible in schools
she says this is if you don't want your
kid reading gay porn in the library then
politely ask the librarian now what are
you talking about
we've got
we've got laws we've got laws against
this for all of our nation's history and
furthermore
we this is a self-government
and so when you say how dare you
how dare you infringe on my right to
make my kid read gay porn when he's 10
years old you don't have that right
that's that's a wrong
and who sets the Civil Rights and Wrongs
well that would be the people in a
self-government that democracy that you
people are always prattling on about
even though you don't believe it at all
all of which is to say the Liberals
obviously don't care about any of this
they're they're just going to wrap
themselves in the flag to Pedal their
radicalism
and it's a political lesson for
conservatives
the libs when they're being really
really effective
they're not burning the American flag
the libs when they're being really
effective they just are lying about
American history
and they're saying oh no my view my
weird trans throppel parading gay porn
down the hallways of elementary schools
why that's as American as apple pie
that's why the founding fathers fought
the Revolution was to defend my right to
do that and it's obviously totally bogus
but that's what they do
they're picking up
a lesson from Machiavelli they're
picking up a lesson from a lot of
political thinkers which is if you want
to be politically effective you got to
wrap yourself in the flag so there's two
ways to do it
you can either do it in the pure will
kind of politics which is
some people see things that aren't say
why I dream things that everyone and say
why not which is the Humpty Dumpty kind
of politics in Alice in Wonderland where
Humpty Dumpty says
what does a word mean it means whatever
I say it means
and Al Alice says well it's got to be
awfully confusing
for words to have all those meanings
the question is do words really mean
those things and Humpty Dumpty says no
no the question is which is to be Master
that's all
that's the the liberal version of it
it's just yeah we'll just whatever we
say that's going to become the truth
because we said it then there's the
conservative version which is what is
the truth you you engage in a rational
process
and you ask yourself questions about
objective reality then you reason
through that using your abstract
reasoning and then
and maybe the inherited wisdom of the
ages and maybe just looking at the
customs of people who already exist and
then you use your will to try to pursue
the truth right now text Knowles kwles
to 98 98 98 the government spending is
out of control long-term bonds have
diminished in value it's crippling Banks
depositors are holding their breath
investors are bailing on Bank stocks you
can't spend your way out of inflation
right now text Knowles kw-l-e-s to 98 98
98 and this volatile Market
diversification has never been more
important that's why buying gold with
Birch gold is such a smart choice gold
is a tangible asset with a reliable
store of value because it's not tied to
any one economy or currency it can be a
safe haven in times of Crisis gold can
help you hedge against inflation because
its value tends to rise when the cost of
living increases unlike other assets
such as paper currency the supply of
gold is limited
which can help to maintain its value
over time Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into a
tax sheltered Ira in physical precious
metals such as gold and silver
time to start thinking about your
Investments and your future you need to
consider diversifying into gold with
Birch gold to die text nulls kwles to 98
98 98 to claim your free info kit on
gold and talk to a precious metals
expert text Knowles to 98 98 98 so when
the conservatives when we wrap ourselves
in the flag
it tends to be because we're making an
argument that really has a basis in
history that's not what the lib's doing
I'm not just making a cheap shot don't
forget the biggest
liberal campaign on education in the
last five or six years was the New York
Times 1619 project
which claimed that American America's
Revolution was fought to preserve
slavery and even left-wing academic
historians said that wasn't true and
when the writer of the 1619 project
Nicole Hannah Jones was confronted by
this she basically Shrugged her
shoulders yeah okay whatever
is the Italian expression you know if
it's not true it makes a good story
and what did the New York Times do
eventually they kind of were forced to
correct it a little bit subtly many
months later but they still continue to
Peddle the 1619 project because they
don't care
politics grounded in the truth or a
politics that is pure will
which one
are we going to have
you see this actually
RFK Jr is running for president now as a
Democrat and RFK Jr is a lifelong
Democrat obviously his father is Robert
Kennedy's uncle's John F Kennedy
and he's been an environmental lawyer
his whole life he actually lived in the
town right over for me when I grew up
and he's a lib he's a real live but he's
gotten a lot of conservative cred
recently because he's questioned
vaccines for a long time
and vaccine skepticism is now
conservative it used to be liberal now
it's conservative after we saw how the
liberal establishment lied to us for the
last three years he questions big Pharma
questions Dr fauci and so he's done a
lot of great work over the last few
years
now
RFK Jr running against Biden and a lot
of conservatives are saying why is he
running as a Democrat he should be
running as a republic he's a republican
these days the Kennedys are Republicans
these days here's what RFK Jr just had
to say on the campaign Trail
we're now
now in this situation where you know
with without
democracy just Withers and dies he's
speech is is the fertilizer it's the
it's the sunlight there's the water for
democracy and you you know nobody
there are there is no time in history
with people who are censoring speech
were the good guys you know they're
always mad guys because of course that's
the
that is the first and last episode
silencing critics so that's the sort of
statement that sounds like it's true but
it isn't really true
it isn't really true because throughout
history everyone everyone ever in power
at all has censored speech and everyone
I don't care how liberal you think you
are you would support some kinds of
limits on speech
this Threat all of history throughout
all of history sometimes the Catholics
have censored speech sometimes the
Protestants have censored speech
sometimes the Jews of censored speech
sometimes the Muslims have censored
speech today we see the atheists
especially censoring speech sometimes
it's been
the Democrats sometimes it's been the
Republicans
sometimes it's been this person or that
and the reason for that as I explained
in my book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds
number one National bestseller hello
hello producers where are you at there
we go all right we're missing Mr Davies
I think
um as I explained in my book speechless
every there we go every culture has to
have certain limits
every culture is going to recognize
certain things as taboo and so
RFK is pointing out that the the current
censorship that's going on is quite
wrong
because it's the libs who we're doing
and they're censoring true
speech but it's not wrong necessarily to
censor false evil ugly speech it's not
wrong to censor
drag queen expression in the elementary
school as I said it's not wrong to
censor the gay porn in the elementary
school libraries I think all of us would
agree that that's a very good thing it's
not wrong to censor threats it's not
wrong to censor fighting words it's not
wrong
to censor all these things it's a very
it's a shallow liberal view that RFK Jr
is expressing
and I think he's doing it with the best
of intentions and he's one of the best
Democrats out there
it's just another reminder liberalism is
not going to save us
even the old liberalism of the 1960s the
Kennedy liberalism even the much older
liberalism The Classical liberalism it's
not going to save us it's just
wrong
you're not going to beat liberalism by
being a different kind of a liberal
you've got to offer
an alternative and the liberal
establishment doesn't like when you
offer an alternative to that
which is why they took Tucker Carlson
off the air and how great was that it
was really incisive and I felt the host
was very handsome make sure you
subscribe at the Michael Knowles show
channel ring that Bell we'll see you
next time
[Music]
oh